oh senor president
[Music]
so
[Music]
templar
madam president
prime minister
honorable members
thank you for organizing this debate
respect for the rule of law is critical
to guarantee well functioning
of the union
the european union
is a union of law and the primacy of eu
law is the foundation of it
in e-architecture primacy of eu law is
the way to guarantee the equal equality
of member state before the treaties
and to ensure that all union citizens
enjoy the same rights
without primacy the application of eu
law would vary from one member to
another
this would destroy the level playing
field in single market
it is also preconditioned for daily
interaction
and for smoothly resolving dispute
it is ultimately the basis for our
living together in a common european
home
the presidency is committed to bringing
forward exchanges
in a positive and constructive
atmosphere on rule of law and related
issues
today at the general affairs council in
the framework of the annual rule of law
dialogue
ministers will be discussing
developments in the area of rule of law
in a general general horizontal debate
the commission's 2021 rule of law report
fits into this exercise and the primacy
of eu law is among the topics covered in
the report
the general affairs council will discuss
again rule of law issues at its session
on 23rd november a country specific
discussion will cover developments in
five main member states namely croatia
cyprus italy latvia and lithuania
the council also reminds
on the article 7 to you procedure
the presidency is committed to advancing
these proceedings
in a council in december
in addition the council continues to
closely monitor the recent rule of law
developments in poland
we aspire for a constructive dialogue
between the commission and poland which
would lead towards converging positions
we will also continue this discussion
within the council
i look forward to your intervention
today
and i also and also to hearing prime
minister moravietsky and how poland sees
the way forward thank you very much for
your attention
thank you president silva pereira
dear prime minister moraviewski dear
minister logar
honorable members
almost 40 years ago
in december 1981
the communist regime in poland imposed
martial law
many members of solidarnosch the
independent trade union of other groups
were put in jail
simply
because they stood up for their rights
the people of poland wanted democracy
like millions of other europeans from
budapest to italian to east berlin
they wanted the freedom to choose their
government
they wanted free speech
and free media
they wanted an end to corruption
and they wanted independent courts
to protect their rights
the people of central and eastern europe
wanted to join
the european family of free people
a strong community of values
and democracy
because that's what europe is about and
that is what europe stands for
and honorable members
the recent ruling of the polish
constitutional court
puts much of it
into question
we have been concerned about the
independence of the judiciary for some
time
judges have seen their immunity being
lifted
and have been driven out of office
without justification
and this threatens judicial independence
which is a basic pillar
of the rule of law
we have taken a number of measures
we continue to have a regular dialogue
but unfortunately the situation has
worsened
and this is not only the commission's
opinion this is what has been confirmed
by the european court of justice and
the european court of human rights
and now this has culminated in the most
recent ruling of the polish
constitutional court
honourable members
the european commission is at the moment
carefully assessing this judgment
but i can already tell you today
i am deeply
concerned this ruling calls into
question the foundations of the european
union
it is a direct challenge to the unity
of the european legal
order only a common legal order provides
equal rights
legal certainty
mutual trust between member states and
therefore common policies
this is the first time ever
that the court of a member state finds
that the eu treaties are incompatible
with the national constitution
and this has serious consequences for
the polish people
because the ruling has a direct impact
on the protection of the judiciary
the ruling undermines
the protection of the judicial
independence
as guaranteed by article 19 of the
treaty and as interpreted by the
european court of justice
without independent courts
people have less protection
and consequently their rights are at
stake
and honorable members
polish people must be able to rely on
fair and equal treatment in the judicial
system just like any other european
citizen
in our union we all enjoy the same
rights
and this basic principle fundamentally
impacts people's lives
because if european law
is applied differently in grenoble or
gertingen or godansk
eu citizens would not be able
to rely on the same rights everywhere
honourable members
when joining the european union the
polish people put their trust in the
european union
they expected the european union to
defend their rights
and rightly so
the commission is the guardian of the
treaty
it is my commission's duty
to protect the rights of eu citizens
wherever they live in our union
the rule of law is the glue that binds
our union together
it is the foundation of our unity
it is essential for the protection of
the values on which our union is founded
democracy
freedom
equality
and respect for human rights
and this is what all 27 member states
have signed up to
as part of this union as sovereign
countries and free people
honorable members
we cannot and we will not allow
our common values to be put at risk
the commission will act
and the options are all known
first option are infringements where we
legally challenge the judgment of the
polish constitutional court
another option
is the conditionality mechanism and
other financial tools
the polish government has to explain to
us
how it intends
to protect european money
given this ruling of their
constitutional court
because in the coming years we will be
investing 2
100 billion euros
with a multi-annual budget and the next
generation eu recovery program
this is european taxpayers money
and if our union is investing more than
ever
to advance our collective recovery
we must protect the union's budget
against breaches of the rule of law
the third option
is the article 7 procedure
this is
the powerful tool in the treaty
and we must come back to it
because let me remind you
the polish constitutional court
that today has ca has cast doubts
on the validity of our treaty
is the same court that under article 7
we consider not to be independent and
legitimate
and this in many ways comes full circle
honorable members
i deeply regret that we find ourselves
in this situation
i've always been a proponent of dialogue
and i will always be
this is a situation
that can
and must be resolved
and we want a strong poland
in a united europe
we want poland to be at the heart of our
debates in building a common future
poland has a stake in europe
together we can build a europe that is
strong and confident in a world where
other big powers become more and more
assertive
europe has benefited from poland's
unique experience so much
without the people of poland
our european journey would have been
very different
when carl weitiwa
as pope john paul ii
went to his homeland
he changed european history forever
whenza with a scattered group of trade
unionists
overcame a mighty army
we saw the beginning of the fall of the
iron curtain
and when president kaczynski
ratified the lisbon treaty
together with the charter fundamental
rights he reaffirmed poland's commitment
to our values
polish people have played a fundamental
role in making our union whole
in enabling their homeland to thrive as
a vital part of our union
and they will always be
polsko
yestesh
is
you will always be at the heart of
europe long live poland and long live
europe thank you
them